I gave some advice as a mom of three to a friendly acquaintance last night
who had just had her second baby
and I thought that somebody else might need to hear it
we were having a conversation and she was talking about how she was doing
she had just welcomed her second son not too long ago
and you know how you can tell that somebody's like
telling you that they're struggling
but they're not telling you in like
those words they're just asking the right kind of questions like
how did you do it
like does it get easier
um you know
we've been coping
like those sorts of kind of
like veiled language
so I could tell like
she was having a hard time
and specifically
this is another person who does content
like specifically like
super creative
like aesthetic
beautiful content that obviously takes a lot of her time and editing and
and energy and I told her that it's just hard
I think so often
we try to pretend that everything is gonna be sunshine and rainbows and like
we've got this mama
you superhero what
yeah go girl
but in reality
when someone struggling
all they wanna know is that like
it's okay that they're struggling
so I basically just told her
I was like it is this hard
it's super fucking hard
this is the chapter of hard
um but it's a temporary chapter
and it does get easier
and you'll get through it
and if you need to take a step back from things that are draining your energy
or resources or time
think that's okay because you're now in a different chapter
it doesn't mean you're always gonna be here
but I think the best advice you can give to a new mom who either has one kid
or two kids or is going through that transition and is having a tough time is
you're having a tough time because it is tough
and the more you can like
settle into the knowledge that it is hard and you're gonna struggle and
and it it's okay
it's it's okay to be having a hard time when
when something's hard
you have to like
surrender to the chapter that you're in
and look to your friends who have been through it
because we're testaments to the fact that you're gonna make it through it too